es ist der seltsamste stern dem
universum beobachtet haben kec 8 28 52
verdunkelt sich so stark und so
unregelmäßig dass ein exo planeten nicht
dafür verantwortlich sein kann
astronomen vermuten deshalb locker
liehen mega strukturen also bauwerke die
so riesig sind dass sie in der lage
wären ganze sterne zu verdanken
jetzt gibt es eine weitere erklärung die
zum seitenwechsel herbst willkommen
wir vermuten hier darüber berichtet beim
stern ki ka 4 6 2 852 gibt es nicht mit
rechten dingen zu 70 trilliarden sterne
gibt es so ungefähr im universum 150000
davon beobachtet das weltraumteleskop
kepler auf der suche nach exoplaneten
damit auf der suche nach einer möglichen
heimat von außerirdischen ein stern
nicht dabei heraus weil es nicht nur
seltsam verhält wie kein anders gestellt
wie 846 2852 babys sterben benannt wurde
er nach der astronomen die ihn zum
ersten mal näher beschrieb und seine
helligkeitsschwankungen untersuchte
gabetta wo ja ja aber auch sie habe
keine erklärung für sein verhalten ein
exoplanet konnte es nicht sein
die schwankungen sind zu unregelmäßig
und zu stark ein cometen schwarm würde
sich so nicht verhalten ein junger stern
dennoch entsteht der bisher hat keine
merkmale eines der zwei planeten stoßen
vor dem stern zusammen
der staub fällt deshalb stellt
astrophysiker jason wright von der penn
state university die these auf dass dort
eine alien zivilisation für die
verdunklung verantwortlich ist seine
idee alien mega strukturen wie zum
beispiel eine riesige tysons wäre eine
hülle um den stern auf dessen innenseite
aliens leben doch dafür fehlen zwei
vermutete eigenschaften von teppich
stern gebe es eine mega struktur mit
sonnenkollektoren oder solarzellen wird
ein infrarot überschuss das von ihm
ausgesendeten lichts erwartet den gibt
es nicht und wti die search for
extraterrestrial intelligence also die
suche nach außerirdischer intelligenz
hat seine radioteleskope auf den stern
ausgerichtet und nichts gefunden wird
keine gnade
da beta pro jahr verlangt für eine
solche these irgendwelche indizien
irgendwelche beweise zitat
außergewöhnliche behauptungen verlangen
nach außergewöhnlichen belegen
ja aber das ist im moment noch einsatz
mit xf geht nichts außer dem
unregelmäßigen flackern aber auch im
gegenzug heißt das nicht denn auch für
alle bisherigen ideen gibt es keine
belege und vielleicht sind die
außerirdischen durchaus so schlau
ansonsten keine beweise für ihre
distanz ins weltall zu schicken das
thema hat mir schon mal im mai selbst
einen neuen abfall der leuchtkraft des
sterns der jetzt mit mehreren teleskopen
parallel beobachten würde darüber hatten
wir berichtet und jetzt gibt es bereits
die erste arbeit die auf den daten
dieser beobachtung bewertung das
ergebnis ist ja sagen wir mal komplex
der spanische astronomen fernando
ballesteros muss die letzten wochen tag
und nacht durchgearbeitet haben um seine
arbeit so schnell fertig bekommen zu
haben seine theorie es ist simpel und
einfach nicht ein objekt sondern es ist
eine komplexe anordnung von mehreren
objekten league am g 8 46 28 52 vorbei
ziehen erstens ist es ein exoplanet
zweitens hat der wieder saturn große
allerdings stark licht schlucken geringe
die sich um in bremen briten kreist ein
dichter aktuellen schwarm um tabus stern
und viertens noch ein wichter aktiven
schwamm um den stern
das ist aber viel auf einmal aber diese
theorie ist wenigstens überprüfbar bei
der theorie sagt nämlich auch die
nächste verdunklung voraus demnach wird
ein asteroiden schwamm anfang 2021
wieder den stand verdunkeln und in der
ersten jahre feste 2023 wird wieder der
ring planet daran vorbei ziehen so seine
vermutung facto nicht ein
ja das sind wir wieder am anfang oder
gibt es vorher indizien oder beweise für
die medien mega struktur müssen wir in
diese richtung weiter forschen auf jeden
fall bleibt es spannend wie immer
erfahrt ihr hier
die aktuelle entwicklung dürfte dafür
einfach hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesslich den auf die glocke ja und
hier geht es weiter mit einem weiteren
video über kiz 86 2 852 alien mega
struktur wieder aktiv da erklärt eine
solche struktur näher einfach
draufklicken meldet euch interessiert
und ansonsten bis dann gleich machen